hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 is here and I can't
wait to talk about it but quickly I'm
going to break down the post-credits
scenes now I'm sorry if there is a bit
of an echo in here we're moving into a
new studio which you can't really tell
because it's the same blue screen but
I'm not lying to you but yeah this
wouldn't be a Marvel movie without
post-credit scenes they want to make
sure we learn the names of all 20
million visual effects artists and yeah
obviously big spoiler warnings here not
just for what's in the post-credits
scenes but for the whole movie of
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 and
what might be coming up in future into
you films I'm just gonna be covering a
lot of stuff so really you should just
go watch the movie don't get mad at me
I'm sensitive okay so here we go games
gun click five beans at the end of this
movie which role during and after the
credits because oh why not
versus these scenes shows the ravager
cracklin who by the way is played by
Sean Gunn brother of director James Gunn
he's wearing yondu's head spin and
practicing whistling to control yondu's
Yaka arrow
given to him by Peter quill after pins
again one last hour here yondu died
sacrificing himself to save Peters and
of course shortly before that yondu told
Peter that he actually controls the
arrow with his heart not just the thin
and whistling and that might be why we
see the arrow go way off target when
cragwitch tries to use it right into
Drax's chest as crackling back to lay
off early now I know this is really just
a funny scene but there may be some
significance to seeing crag land
received yondu's iconic weapons like it
could be implying that in the third
guardians movies which is happening
scramblin might take over as the sort of
successor as the wall lift
but pragmatic Ravager that yondu always
was it's also rumored that Sean Gunn
might appear in the infinity Wars movies
so we may be seen him even further than
that okay moving on this second scene
shows Sylvester Stallone's
characteristic ro board assembling
various Ravager leaders to carry on
yondu's mission and steal some okay
so who are all these people so there is
Charlie 27 that's played by Bing Raines
and Artie next is played by Michael
Rosenbaum aka Lex Luthor from Smallville
and then a letter that's Michelle Yeoh
there's also mainframe and I don't know
if we caught this but that voice is my
siren now all these guys were actually
part of the original Guardians team in
the comic run in the 60s so it's pretty
cool to see James Gunn bringing them all
back together like this also this red
dude is Krueger and notice how he's
harnessing mystical energy the same
exact visual style of Doctor Strange
and that's because in the comics this
character is connected to Doctor Strange
he actually succeeds them as the
sorcerer supreme
now if the car is a super interesting
character in the movie doesn't really
get into his comic backstory like he's
just a rabbit or captain here but in the
comics he's known as star hawk and his
story lies involved time travel
he actually relived his life over and
over again he's very cool character now
I'm not sure if the third movie will get
into all that stuff or how much that
movie will feature all of these guys but
Gunn has said that he enjoyed working
with Miley Cyrus even though she just
has like one line here and he might have
more in store for her characters okay
moving on a little later in the credits
things kids interesting we see Aisha
licking her wounds plotting her revenge
revealing that she engineered a new
being that's the next stage of their
evolution just to destroy the Guardian
then we see this golden birthing pod and
we hear faint heartbeats and Aisha says
I think I shall call him Adam so she's
obviously referring to Adam warlock in
the comics Adam warlock is also referred
to as him he's a genetically perfect
super powerful being designed by a group
of scientists called The Enclave to be
an even more perfect version of Aisha
she's actually called her but now it
seems like Adam warlock origin it's
being tweaked so that Aisha created him
like the superior race of the sovereign
is creating an even more purely superior
being also James gonna said that that
Adam warlock Queen Easter egg that he
put in the first Guardians movie was
kind of a mistake he just minted as a
joke then so that's why this cocoon has
a different booking design here now that
the character is actually joining the
narrative now Adam warlock is an awesome
character in the comics he actually
plays a big role in the Infinity Jim arc
gun actually wanted him to be in this
movie but Saul said it already had
plenty of other characters and
storylines going on so we don't want to
over complicate things it also sounds
like warlocks won't be part of the
infinity ward's movies but he will come
back and guardians the galaxy vol 3 and
when we're quick
even though I doubt this is the case but
if you remember early in the film it
hinted that I so wanted to experiment
with Peter to reproduce the
old-fashioned way which I assume means
like doggy style I'm a traditionalist
anyway that never happens in this movie
I'm pretty sure the Guardians lead to
sovereign immediately after that
conversation but wouldn't it be awesome
if we later learn that it did happen and
part of Ayesha's formula for this
superior being included some of Peters
DNA I mean we do learn that he is the
son of a celestial in this movie like
that could be part of the explanation of
how they're able to improve on they're
already kind of perfect genetic code and
if so that what set of some more
interesting daddy issues with likes our
Lord and his son Adam warlock we'll see
okay moving on this sports scene
actually does show what star-lord as a
father figure might look like we see
Peter bickering with Ruth who has now
aged into this moody teenager his room
is a mess covered in vines and he
sarcastically I am groups at Peter as he
plays a videogame see her so fast all
day yeah Peter don't look too closely
around that room you might find some
tissues with tree sap in it but
seriously Bruce is growing super fast
like he was just a potted plant a few
months earlier in the timeline and then
now he was a baby in this movie and it
sounds like we'll see an even more fully
formed version of group beyond his size
in the first movie moving on to this
final scene which plays actually at the
end of the credits
it shows Stanley in his fishbowl helmet
spacesuits rambling on with these guys
now these are Watchers in the comics
they're all seen cosmic beings who
observe intelligent life throughout the
universe now if you remember this scene
is a call back to the earlier Stan Lee
cameo where yondu and rocket are passing
through various dimensions including one
with thin telling the watchers about the
time he was a FedEx guy referencing his
cameo in Captain America Civil War and
now they're just like P and they leave
him behind without a ride home now it's
actually pretty interesting to see
Stanley
hanging out with the watchers because
here's a weird theory in the comics
there's The Watcher character who lot to
who's kind of main one and it's possible
that family roped himself into the
comics as his character because think
about it
Stan Lee shows up in so
many different superhero universes he
kind of liked his own watcher in the
cinematic world it would explain how
he's able to break out of the MCU and
then suddenly show up hanging out with
spider-man and before you judge me this
theory isn't too out there one person
who does agree with it and did put this
connection in there for that reason is
James Gunn okay so those are all the
post-credits scenes for guardians the
galaxy vol 2 but keep an eye out for
more videos that we got coming out for
this movie including a full breakdown of
all the Easter eggs and the awesome song
choices in this movie like yes they are
fun and catchy but they also have a
deeper layer of meaning that connects to
why the characters are doing things and
if you like this video please hit like
and subscribe the new rock stars and
share this video with all your friends
you can also contribute to us on patreon
thanks so much to all of our current
patrons actually my good buddy from
college Chris quell dude let's catch up
I take a clip on your shirt anyway Chris
and everyone else watching you can hit
me up on twitter at you gave us with any
thoughts you have about guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 let me know what you
thought of it I love this movie I can't
wait to talk about it more you gonna
have to follow do rock stars on Twitter
at new rock stars for different updates
on all of our videos alright thanks for
watching bye
you